♪
STEVE: WELCOME BACK.
OUR NEXT GUEST IS SOUNDING THE
ALARM FROM THE FRONT LINES OF
THE BORDER CRISIS.
THE MAYOR OF LAREDO, TEXAS,
BEGGING A FEDERAL JUDGE TO STOP
THE BUSES PACKED WITH
COVID-POSITIVE MIGRANTS FROM
FLOODING INTO HIS CITY.
THIS AS MORE THAN 280 MIGRANTS
HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO LAREDO
SHELTERS SINCE SUNDAY, AT LEAST
75 OF THEM ARE COVID-POSITIVE.
THAT’S ABOUT 25% ARE
COVID-POSITIVE.
LAREDO, TEXAS, WHERE THE MAYOR
JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR TAKING AN
INTEREST IN THE BORDER.
STEVE: IT’S OF GREAT INTEREST TO
EVERYBODY.
S THAT IS WHY YOU HAD TO DECLARE
A DISASTER THE OTHER DAY TO ASK
A JUDGE, PLEASE TELL THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO STOP IS FLOODING
OUR STREETS WITH THESE
COVID-POSITIVE MIGRANTS AND
MIGRANTS IN GENERAL.
WE JUST DON’T HAVE ENOUGH ROOM,
RIGHT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH, WE’VE BEEN -- IT’S TRULY A
CRISIS.
IT’S A TRIPLE CRISIS.
WE HAVE A BORDER SECURITY
CRISIS, WE HAVE A HEALTH CRISIS
HERE IN OUR CITY, IN THE AREA,
AND, OF COURSE, WE HAVE A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS AS WELL.
AND IT’S ALL AS A RESULT OF THIS
HUGE INFLUX OF MIGRANTS THAT ARE
COMING IN THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
BORDER AREA AND, OF COURSE,
LAREDO’S NO EXCEPTION.
OUR SITUATION IS COUNTING ON IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE MIGRANT WITHS
BEING BUSSED -- MIGRANTS BEING
BUSSED TO THE LAREDO AREA
BECAUSE THE RGV, WHICH IS ABOUT
150 MILES DOWN RIVER OF LAREDO,
IS JUST OVERWHELMED.
I THINK THEY’VE HAD OVER 400,000
MIGRANTS SINCE OCTOBER 1ST, I
BELIEVE.
SO WE’RE NOW THE PLACE WHERE
THEY’RE BRINGING THESE MIGRANTS
FOR FURTHER PROCESSING.
YESTERDAY WE DID REACH AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE BORDER
PATROL, SO THERE’S NO NEED TO
CONTINUE THE LAWSUIT.
BUT IT’S TEMPORARY.
NOW THE CITY OF LAREDO PROPER
WITH TAXPAYER MONEY, WE’RE
FINANCING THE BUSING OF THESE
MIGRANTS FURTHER NORTH INTO
TEXAS SO THEY CAN REACH THEIR
DESTINATIONS.
SO IT’S BECOME SO COMPLICATED,
STEVE.
STEVE: NO KIDDING.
AND, MAYOR, THE PRESIDENT WAS
ASKED THE OTHER DAY ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, HE’S CONCERNED WITH PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY HAVING COVID,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER SEEMS TO BE WIDE
OPEN, AND THE PRESIDENT CITED
TITLE 42 SAYING WE’RE TURNING
EVERYBODY AROUND AT THE BORDER,
SAYING YOU CAN’T COME IN BECAUSE
OF COVID.
HE SAID THE ONLY PEOPLE BEING
LET IN ARE CHILDREN.
YOU’RE SEEING THE PEOPLE.
I’M LOOKING AT THE VIDEO.
THEY’RE LETTING IN A LOT MORE
THAN KIDS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT’S THESE FAMILY UNITS AND, OF
COURSE, THEY BRING THE CHILDREN
SO FAMILY MEMBERS CAN ALSO TAG
ALONG.
AND, AGAIN, IT’S THE ASYLUM SEEK
ISERS.
THE POLICY IS THERE -- SEEKERS.
BUT OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING’S
TERRIBLY WRONG HERE.
OF IT’S NOT ORDERLY, THERE’S
CHAOS AND, OBVIOUSLY, IT’S
CREATING THIS CRISIS THAT WE’RE
FACING HERE THROUGHOUT THE
BORDER AREA.
SO WE’RE ASKING FOR RESOURCES.
IF YOU’RE INSISTING ON THIS
POLICY, ENFORCE IT, YOU KNOW?
MAKE IT WORK --
STEVE: RIGHT.
>> -- TOTALLY ON THE FEDERAL
NICKEL.
DON’T EXPECT THE LOCAL AALS
TO -- LOCALS TO, YOU KNOW,
EXPEND MONEY TO HELP THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WE CAN DO OUR PART --
STEVE: NO KIDDING.
>> THAT’S ALL WE CAN DO.
STEVE IF THE FEDS ARE GOING TO
ASK YOU TO TAKE ALL THESE
PEOPLE, THEY SHOULD AT LEAST
HELP YOU WITH THE MONEY.
YOU COULD USE IT.
MAYOR PETE SIGNS, THANKS VERY